okay Wow like it's like if you can't
kill anyone and you're shooting at them
the way they're said that you I don't
understand
I just we're worst fire team ever right
yeah I think that's our Twitter
that's our Twitter's 4.5 kg baby
well here we go here we go now I got
lucky I got here we go I'm gonna regret
what I just said I wish you guys at the
point where you were just the best so
you could just beat coke I just want to
see you Salton once in a while wow I'm
gonna kill them dude in a game in a game
who's recording uh yeah come with Eric
Griffin's the leaders well I'm joining
your fire I'm drawing your team
whoever's team yeah what are we doing
are we doing trials what are we doing
hey banana Steve Arthur come on I'm
hyped let's do it Steve no no we want
use Stephen Arthur it's just like
subunit now okay yeah okay yeah yeah
we'll rotate yeah we rotate that's what
I'm yeah the best don't ask me what I'm
using you know I get so defensive when
people ask knows Griffin
redzone Steve I've seen Steve do that so
much I feel like that I just I see I see
his face when he says his face when he
starts to get angry like I'm feeling
good are you talking about oh it's all
night
all they do back they go in viz
oh oh I like how it looks
Wow turn around back coming behind oh I
just do the worst grenade in history you
my god they what the whole team out man
I should have killed that guy you know
what we're not communicating the Annis
hope that all right are you guys we need
to talk
there we go there we go hit him good
good T nice yeah there's nothing on down
there they'll be careful hey don't
forget to put up your oh my god you got
this you got this Griffin just take them
off take them off you know what I don't
want to say it you know what I'm not
gonna say it but we need someone don't
say it but you know what else do you
think guns are using oh we got a kill
right all right let's go
oh [ __ ] we need some backup man he came
around they flanked us you know what Oh
Maurice buddy I'm still having fun man
I'm still having fun man hey heavy heavy
[ __ ] man
they got me at the smoke and nothing
guys can win laughing oh my god we need
a plan what's our plan damn it [ __ ]
they're flankin does he smoke this in
their flanking bridge that's why I don't
like right here I feel great I killed
one guy I feel good about it yeah
one guy started to kill the guard
shotgun Wow like it's like if you can't
kill anyone
and you're shooting at them the way
they're at you I don't understand
I just who's left to live
oh man you [ __ ]
dude we got trying to have fun yeah but
our first team we got is like [ __ ]
this way come back out oh [ __ ] behind
you that little riff shoot my god dude
first rate him no we're not like you're
gonna get frustrating
there we got them Jesus you guys
freaking out I know and then I died oh I
killed three people killed a couple
we're not doing that bad
oh go ahead dance on my [ __ ] corpse
[ __ ] yesterday it doesn't matter
Arthur you did you are getting better
dude I could I tell I could tell the
other day you're like alright guys we
get I got a ghost we got do one know
what I gotta go
alright let me just get my cards in this
fast we don't have to reset it why did
you play trials already I did yesterday
I told you what the evil people yeah
let's go let's go let's go
are you right anyway that was that was a
tough team to start with though and that
[ __ ] autumn wind I'm gonna try my
autumn wind see what's up with this do
it fast
switch I switched you just saw for
yourself we are the worst don't support
that [ __ ] what do you say I'm just
kidding
no nothing everybody's backs up Montez
he's right deservedly so deservedly so
about cheese
alright you you know what Pikachu you
lead the charge
private Pikachu you tell us what to do
you do it easily
no no you know right a Pikachu you know
what Arthur I'm gonna follow you Arthur
you know what that they believe in your
kin
do it anymore I'm a father Arthur do it
anyway so just follow Arthur he's gonna
do what he's gonna do anyway he's like
he was like I'm a follower without the
kills I got kills last time about their
kills he got the most cute
you got like seven kills do you see a
black panther Stevie no I haven't seen I
don't hear anything about it I want to
see it dude how come you haven't seen it
yet okay okay we should be able to beat
this team this is not a sweaty team how
do you know I'm looking at the looking
oh he's looking them up on destiny fund
on that yeah we should be able to do
these dudes what's up banana how you
doing banana he's good yeah he's here I
miss you guys
oh this is great I can just gonna just
your thing this is dope I got the big
enjoy you're in a game that's what I'm
about I'm about fashion fashion what
does that dance that's what dance is
that Steve and then they're all - all my
toe
oh that's the Beyonce all right is that
the Beyonce dance I don't know it's
multi to my demise yeah but at least
it's argh straighter okay at least we
can beat this it's not a whole team of
freaking you know and there yeah nice
Dockers yeah this is doable
all right see we'll see well that's good
okay pride Pikachu
Paul pride Pikachu let's just roll
together all right they're coming I'm
gonna throw this up so we can guard
heavy there goes a grenade
I can't even see any that got back up
back there trying to come behind you
there flanked me they flanked me
yeah they wiped our whole good job so
annoying just don't let them get heavy
whatever you do try not to let them get
heavy yeah let's go for heavy go for
heavy yeah all right I'm coming you
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's right down there
behind you I know I just died I don't
it's like right now I want to punch my
right in the middle of the [ __ ]
screen I just don't get it and do like
50 pushups
alright okay so let's stick together
let's stay back kick it right here let's
go Pikachu pika Chu Chu is in the middle
let's stay here here stay here in the
middle cuz they're gonna go for heavy
see there's this guy [ __ ] you I need
help though there's nobody by the ref
but I'm in the middle you guys are on
the right I say metal you're on the
right this is the problem like something
we're not talking she just said stay to
the right
oh there's 1071 [ __ ] trousers ones no
wonder jeez they're not good
yes I didn't see that going to let you
shield someone I got a kill I just got a
kill what a miracle just it felt good
wank around come on how this [ __ ] is he
hitting me more than I've been him oh
alright this next round everyone stick
together and we're gonna push around in
a circle okay I'll get to the middle I
love you alright which way which way
we're gonna go I don't know I got see
which way we're gonna spawn in alright
we're gonna go right go just go right
okay all the way let's go yeah let's go
all the way let's go all the way there
right here let's go all the way all
right keep pushing pushing up top watch
out there name
there's a guy flanking there's a guy
Frankie
I know mine doesn't either dude yeah
yeah I'm good I'm shooting I'm shooting
blanks man like diehard like diehard -
how the [ __ ] this is my kill streak this
PJ unbelievable get Americ oh my god
like we're shooting at each other now
Steve take him out take him out you got
him you got him all bro you got this
just five kills just five I knows all
right guys come on come on come on we're
coming [ __ ] we're coming oh my god had
a five kill streak Eric I mean the guy
is not healing close to getting by super
right now they're all gonna get our
super now with that attitude I just
don't understand how yes I just died I
just fell off the screen because I
didn't I was stunned that I even bought
of here I killed the guy disbelief and I
fell off the screen Eric how pathetic is
that saw that I know I couldn't believe
I killed our trip is that it for us yeah
I gotta go guys all right all right
which people
I don't know if I need no come on
I know you just got to get better at
aiming you got jump into this coke no
yeah right foot this is the good foot
this is the good foot we let's do let's
do all right what do you want to do pub
no no we're doing this no what are you
getting warmed up well let's do one with
banana let's do one banana then let's
play some pub G coz that we gotta get
people want to see coke play pub G
alright yeah they actually do want to
see him play okay who do we gettin in
here
you haven't played with the squad how
are you getting in here yeah we might
think I'm pretty good in that game well
banana want to join us yeah yeah we're
in orbit and then whoa we'll play one
game with this if we do well you know
we'll go with this card and otherwise
we'll jump the pub and we'll play some
one coke cuz we got to get some of that
there go let's do this let's do it how's
your day going
cool yeah let me know how that goes so
pretty exciting you see black panther
weight pika did you watch it twice no
I'm gonna see it again was that good I
thought it was good I wanna see it again
because the people next to me were being
really rude and they kept touching my
hey I think I don't know I hope
everybody's touching your leg that's the
right thing all right let's at least try
to get it let's try to at least went
around can we at least try to win Iran I
think we can went around did somebody
like so yeah it's a nice doctor [ __ ]
dude it's a nice side of the cloaking
bullsh yeah is it a cheap cuz I'm using
my truck and I'm getting killed so it's
cheap you can abuse it so bad yeah the
Amos sucks
yeah and heal up ya know it sucks dude
and such mean yet to play against
multiple they they're just all [ __ ]
donut biz right his ridiculous
it's disgusting around corners over and
over I was tagging the dude and he would
just he would envision just ran away and
I couldn't even follow my gun one track
and then it's like oh alright yeah
that's true ok so you talk about dodging
you turn invisible that's the one I have
it on is your shadow
that's what you should do just do that
Steve going visit try to take out
everybody mine doesn't last that long I
don't know what you guys are talking
about though it doesn't last as long as
you guys are saying well it doesn't
listen once you shoot once you shoot
you're not busy anymore
oh but just enough to get away yeah
oh nothing oh all right let's go what
are we doing hey they can't hear coach
no cream oh yeah coach Carter and cokes
gotta add his audio and put it down yeah
yeah there you go
I'm here there you go this is hurt he's
gonna go for heavy what coming to you I
got one guy all right let's push yeah
watch out he's got rockets don't watch
this guy he's got rockets yeah me too
yeah
douche yeah but you know what we can
take these guys dude we can he's just
because he got heavy dude
vulgar it's all you bro just four more
kids six more kills six more kills a lot
of people are using them yeah a lot of
people are using some machines looking
great on top of the board all right all
right guys
right side keep pushing pika
let's push around push around push
around push around one of them's coming
Bridge
ah Jesus Christ
together we gotta be all together yeah
that Titan got five of us have you have
you have heavy yeah let's go go go go go
just go on you're 60 good let's go quick
they got it already got it they got it
watch out just get out my god with the
last pumpkin ah damn it are you [ __ ]
kidding me
[ __ ] you you're a spy yeah I'm just
getting pushed by two oh we're already
out of lives
yeah we're done yep Johnny Jesus who's
left who's left Oh Pikachu Pikachu come
on you got this just like ten kills you
got this his last hope they're just like
pushing hard
you can choose what's going on you were
getting okay okay okay okay
where you go yeah they're all there
middle watch out we got it we got to
secure heavy like that's the problem if
you lose heavy and these guys get it
there it's like an automatic to kill
heavies coming up heavies coming up
pikachu's let's let's try get to hell my
god [ __ ] I can't get it dude there's
guys on a five days we got to get to
have you when it comes up we've got to
get to have you dude cuz now that that's
just one side right side they got it got
the heavy
I know because nobody was there except
for me we got it cuz then when I called
it out we know I know I know cliff
that's just great I'm not even dying by
them I'm dying by the screen one more
after this we can't that's fine cokes
and burritos
spelling a [ __ ] check Stevie we be Oh
not doing good come on let's go let's go
right let's go right hold on Evie right
and hold off HEVC watch out come in come
in they're all they're trying to hold
off heavy come on up come up let's go
Bridge five too late
Jesus Christ they're going operational
strange yeah we needed to know this
mansion we need a team shoot all right
happy heavies coming bum-rush heavy
bum-rush heavy if anybody's got grenades
thriller
starter house anybody get heavy oh my
god they're coming squadron dude you see
them all running in and all together
well cause he's got fish cuz yes yeah
yeah I got this guys I got this don't
worry I'm gonna bring it back bring it
back here just need 15 kills you got a
Craig nice shield deuces
this ain't Iraq were you hiding in a
corner for well I got that that was
ridiculous oh my god we are getting
chewed up tonight oh yeah hey but we're
happy thanks all right yeah it's fun I
mean I don't know you know you guys what
peeks what goes on with you I know you
can get like 17 kills I know
peak peak seven not one match he's not
playing yeah how he can play I know dude
if Peaks got two kills there we might be
up all around okay okay okay I'm sorry I
know what it is you guys stop rolling we
using the wrong way should we go Auto
rifle I don't understand I just feel
like they're just beating us to the
punch it's just a team shooting and just
yeah they're toting we're definitely not
so heavy heavy heavy comes in the middle
pretty quickly when you start match okay
like it's usually 30 seconds out so we
got to get to the middle and you know
what I say if we go outside the defender
and hold middle just hold middle from
outside yeah if we're inside let's go
straight toward middle and defend it and
like okay just stay back and defend it
we don't have to rush up all right okay
commentary lead the way no I'm just
saying he's like what determines some of
these rounds maybe you guys all got
taken out by that
what's a stupid
yeah well I mean that's the thing if one
of us uses a rocket launcher we get
heavy then we ply at least got a killer
too and I mean yeah and then you get and
then you get a good minute and a half
before we gotta go back in okay well do
you know I'm just telling you I'm just
saying yeah that's what everybody does
they go for heavy but they're not just
doing that there are doing more
efficient teamwork sure no no no no
they're doing team shooting too but we
get split up after chaos starts to
happen so yeah
stick with the buddy she knows yeah yeah
Oh Stevie I'm gonna show Vic what your
helmet sick yeah it's the UM I put that
extra um you know like that extra
ornament on it or the making a hood yeah
I don't know it's samurai there we go at
least they're not all night stocking
yeah we got a world walker and [ __ ]
yeah I got [ __ ] flaws we got our
striker
we got normal [ __ ] yeah muttering
flawless go to the right again
now go to the center go to Senator
Daniel what is it heavy yeah right for
the heavy don't go all the way in
Pikachu don't push all the way up stay
back here they're gonna throw grenades
and [ __ ] to come and laughs so here
throw this they're probably gonna come
over bridge let's back up a little
we can cover from here see they're
coming around left and bridge there I'll
topple yeah and there's one coming left
there he is left
I got one nice nice there's this -
somebody get heavy somebody get heavy
they'll get heavy who's ever over there
one poor I got it grab it grab it grab
it
cover me cover it there we go good there
he's got talking about now we got some
advantage good job okay I'm coming I'm
coming
don't waste it wait to see him Brodie
shooting that you just see I got a kill
did you alright nevermind then
good job I take back what I said Pikachu
you're the best nice you got to push on
the last one last two there we go
perfect ornate right behind behind
behind yep
he's panic though he's hurt there we go
nice vulgar there's no dude to your
right we got him we got him cover middle
cover middle I don't know I'm back just
they're gonna come for it they're coming
row I guess her but I'm hurt so I got a
backup
she's hiding they're pushing it on the
hubby I push it on heavy Oh Mike I know
I need help
sorry I was reloading I think I've been
a heavy fog had to have you all right
it's all right it's all right sorry just
keep keep going you old fast
second one all you got YouTube you know
I was a different guy all right well
Rockets is out whoo
at least a week this week it like what
Chevy we can't compete with these guys I
think yeah but let's go help the boys
help the boys
there we go nice they're pushing hard
now so there you go Steve I can't I
can't get there I can't get there I
can't get that there we go he's nice we
got one more life rift put down your
wrist nice Stevie I need help i need
help he's right there
you see you're right [ __ ] that was a
good comeback though we actually came
back good skew against one he's gonna
get heavy I tried man we got you wait
the [ __ ] oh whoa I was trying do five
kill streak i heavy let's go toward
heavy let's block it like we did first
round I'm gonna go up on bridge here
yeah I'm on top left side drag to your
left
yeah I know
he's dead now he traded you you got him
Thanks yeah I got him
but everybody's dying be up in ten seven
six and watch all the distance there
just wait for it don't grab it Stevie if
you're is it you can you can get it
there we go nice he's going for it don't
let me get it
god damn it we flank me bridge left side
all right need help [ __ ] oh he's letting
slip he's hurt he's going for heavy uh
where is everybody
spawning spawning yeah [ __ ] we need to
capitalize on a heavy I should have put
a shield up over there
all right backing off guard yeah there's
a [ __ ] there's the [ __ ] they still
got three lives [ __ ] me dude I was off
on my shooting yeah [ __ ] mob justice
coming my steve-o back
oh you got me god damn it sorry guys how
you doing good
watch out good work doable I don't know
what my eyes are watering eyes are
watering so bad cuz you're staring cuz I
know at least we're doing better we got
around
we got around yeah we got around we can
do more than that dude if you can get
heavy if we can secure heavy dude we can
get we can do this you know what I mean
yeah wait till they get close I get
close yeah go in there just wait till I
get closer when they get close I
surrender it's 16 seconds so and when it
gets to like when it gets like five
seconds Stevie yeah when it gets to five
seconds go into the right there all
right Stevie if you can get over there
and just go by the heavy one down there
you go there you go push push there we
go
one more nice beautiful beautiful nice
good [ __ ] boys yeah heavy regroup
regroup regroup they're coming right now
behind us behind us where we came in
all right nice good [ __ ] where we came
where we spawn there's another guy
jumping around outside
push push push push all right the other
ones coming back out beautiful bow
Stevie that was a plan we did a plan and
it worked right we did our plan we both
the heavy and it worked all right here I
got my special I got my special be smart
about it just terrible
yeah I'm gonna throw that down there I'm
gonna come out when it gets supposed to
have you oh nice oh my god are you
kidding heavies up heavies an 8 inch
stomach for it
[ __ ] heavys up all right I'm coming up
wow they got me now the dance is all
about I didn't over bomb you all right
that's fine they wasted their Nova on
one person hold on hold on we are we are
see this is a fun match I'm actually
having fun I don't carefully lose this
one cuz it was a competitive at least
you know to me right there bastard yeah
take that [ __ ] art there's one left is
one left Stevie it's you and the guy so
watch out oh no where is he he's in
there is it where remember don't forget
your invisibility I don't have to see
him but ladies you're right he's got
lasso top top top is to your left to
your left behind you
oh there's two guys oh that's too long
now three of them there's three I feel I
don't know if I'm gonna cry or laugh I'm
just like so filled with emotion you
know - super so just be careful they're
gonna pop out with something one guys
coming right
I think he's flanking yeah I think this
guy's flanking
that was terrible banner yep there goes
this [ __ ] Nova he wasted on one
person oh [ __ ]
thank you there you go heavy I'm coming
back Oh cook well
nice beautiful coming to you Stevie
what a [ __ ] nice pica cheeks right side
right side [ __ ] slam em back up
I'm trying team shoot team shoot there
we go I need this Kenny help with this
guy [ __ ] he's right there's my bad
yeah was my bad ok there we go there we
go I couldn't do much more than that
guys we need to you do good I'm back I'm
back I'm back in three on three I'm back
I got a boat - should I use it or no
wait no no well yeah if it gets to the
last man this is it so okay just tell me
I could use it whenever how the [ __ ] did
he shoot me
ah yeah I mean just use it to save the
round if you can get them there's three
alive was 3 B 3 so just stick together
oh yeah you got a unit Steve oh my god
what where's the other guy I don't know
where you even shooting a stiff stay
where you're at get the heavy no this
one this guy next door [ __ ] [ __ ] Stevie
alright on his own he's capturing the
point watch out you gotta get him
he's behind you behind you hot dog good
try good try
can we go again cuz that was really fun
yeah that was good I mean I feel like we
did I mean we at least competed we tried
yeah we tried we tried kills we got good
do 20 seconds we beat them on three
points that's the [ __ ] saddest part
is just yeah yeah I mean it was just I
guess they had better tactics or
something yeah it's all about
disappearing they're heavier at least
getting them out of there when the heavy
you know yeah they're going there I mean
how the [ __ ] we losing we have almost 30
kills or 20 kills each you know that's
[ __ ] eyeball goes my mind right
that's a lot of kills at least that's at
least like two rounds each almost yeah
but we're trying too often yeah yeah
it's just you know what it is like it's
just about the heavy in this thing
because everybody bum rushes for heavy
and like that one time when you when you
hit that arrow right when they're all
there see I was a good plan we can take
down all three and push that was great
yeah see that that was worth playing if
we could every round was like I mean
every you know match was like that I'd
want to play on that and we got to call
out our supers we got to call out our
soup yeah that's the other thing like my
kids have used my boy wisely that last
match I didn't know how many how many
people are actually on the board like
cuz I thought there was only one it was
yeah no no it was three it was 3v3 and
then he could it would just happen quick
Pikachu it down and then glad just went
down and then but I think did you trade
Galactus at the end there the last one
yeah very last one
yeah Trading I got stuck there was
another guy I was chasing after one guy
that was really fun though that was a
fun match guys you have to admit was
that that's why I like playing video
games is cuz of those moments it was
like okay they're beating us we're
beating
it's like it's even you know it's not
like a shutout you know yeah I like that
we'll see it before night stockers this
time are you sure no I'm just saying
we'll see okay we got we got lucky with
like teams that weren't yeah Knights
talking the whole time and sweaty yeah
they were beatable yeah definitely you
know we could have beat them Craig come
on and they had a guy that went flawless
ten times yeah that's true too they did
our guy was flawless ten times so is
that is that ficer havoc the best option
what about that Sentinel shield you
haven't seen you use that Craig I'm
telling you it's so hard to use bro
I usually use my slam when my slam I'll
get two kills usually wait this is same
guys same dude that's alright well let's
show that's fine let's show him we can
win all right the same guys we just be I
mean they just beat us yeah yeah I've
gotta beat them yeah okay there's their
second chance at it okay so all right
let's go middle middle let's cover
middle I'll cover left flank
I'll cover I'm gonna be with you in left
link to bridge right there coming from
the left all right
just just cover heavy guys if you can
get there one down you go left side
there's another one it's going oh my god
my [ __ ] watch out Steve oh you
[ __ ] got me we gotta get heavy
heavies up heavies up yeah I mean I'm
not gonna be able to get there [ __ ] man
they took it already got I know but like
if we're if two people are holding off
guys on the left and somebody's got to
try to run in and grab heavy or
something cuz otherwise we're just
giving oh yeah I just got work lift yeah
I just got work with yeah yeah that's it
yeah they wipe me out I'm done
good job vulgar yeah they're blinking
all over the place like a bunch of
douches hold on okay together stay
together
stay together middle there is
choo-choo-choo there we go there we go
nice 10e nice Bolger where's the last
time push push push - guys he's running
there we go yeah oh right in front of me
[ __ ] I [ __ ] that up
he's right there Stevie going behind you
are you ran away watch out behind you
bottoms you peek at you behind you
booger watch out
I don't know so you guys got this push
together push together Gabi Gabi
Stevie inside guys I know much much much
rush yeah heavy don't let him get heavy
I got it yeah that's I'm talking about
just a somebody stay on the point dude I
mean once don't get no good job good job
guys there you go Arthur that's the guys
were looking for he's back uh heavy
let's go it's control middle control you
know if you guys got like vortex
grenades throw it in there like make it
off I will but it's not up yet it's wait
till it's closer that guy's gonna play
Flint
it's right here play their blanket yeah
it's like all right you got him
I don't write good I need this nice good
job with the okay don't let him get the
help of course push push push push
he's right there get him get him
he's that hit the heavy get babby oh my
god
nice Pikachu that's good though that's
good yeah yeah just find it and you got
a clue yeah that's all that matters I
City go back with you let's just manage
three - yeah he's hardscoping he's
hardscoping he's hardscoping wide-eyed
alright okay let's come they have to
push us we don't have to push them yeah
we have anybody
there we go
we have the rift up
don't go crazy yeah don't push too hard
stay up there's four Vil I'm back I'm
back I'm back I'm going up top
[ __ ] you man [ __ ] [ __ ] push yeah
we got a mission
oh dude oh my he's he [ __ ] plate me
someone's gonna kill oh my god
God stop die oh my oh my god okay it's
okay
yes mom you know what though guys with
me that life in marriage let's hang back
hang back hang back cuz two of you guys
ran in there when they were in there
yeah I got cocky I know don't get cocky
dude because they were on a rift and
then they had a life event you got we
had life events they have to come to us
you know what I mean
let's play smart oh my god that kill all
right good
[ __ ] Cranky's lately let o Hosey
not dead the riff heavy heavy heavy yeah
they're right there oh [ __ ] yeah they're
doing the same strategy they're both on
the bridge it sound good
alright stay I'll turn back see outside
yeah hey someone left on their team
nice we'll take it nice watch the fight
watch it looks like coming coming coming
coming
oh my god behind us thanks Craig I'm out
he's dead there we go
oh good job guys
there's three [ __ ] back up back up let's
just stay back here I got my super throw
a shield up don't waste to us yeah
you swing flanking from right thank you
from the right yeah we have Banerjee
we have Vantage spa I find poachy
all right let's stay relaxed
yeah uncover heavy don't go crazy
top top right I can't believe it all
right she's coming around right just
Stevie watch that flank yeah I'm coming
in with you Stevie okay whoa whoa what I
want to throw him in there so he didn't
it's around the corner
Arius peekaboo he's down let's go oh
wait there's another one stage station
he's got a fish down I got that guy then
I got the middle back the middle I'm
here I'm here come around no no no no we
took life advantage we have way life
advantage bro six three oh they're
coming to the right side
oh yes nice nice nice nice he's smart
I'm smart middle bridge right bridge
yeah he's hurt he's [ __ ] her to chase
him on that side I'm flanking from the
right side Oh
storm chances storm chance you gotta
pocket got amis don't trance it down
good job oh my god all right just live
we have 25 seconds we have three lives
don't die just live we have life
advantage
watch out to you cuz the guy has a slam
he might use it oh yeah that's why I
don't use my Galactus [ __ ] it don't push
don't push all right good good job but
heavy you got a heavy hole we're all
[ __ ] around we still won wait till it
gets no wait till it gets down to like
two like a couple seconds right now it's
at 20 seconds they're coming to me
fridge left yeah I should I got him up
there Steve be ready to shoot that bow
middle when it's like five seconds okay
[ __ ] behind me
[ __ ] [ __ ] shoot it shut off back off
back off nobody go push on it go push on
get heavy hey come here me me oh [ __ ] oh
my god mr. hag back off that was why you
got the heavy Craig so only you died
yeah I did but I got one guy I kind of I
kind of was jumping into him and I
didn't have a lot of propulsion
propulsion levitation propulsion another
touch and let's go Stevie push push push
Thank You Craig [ __ ] that guy oh you
gotta get behind me I need help he's
behind me we're like way behind you yeah
drop packet right now that's what I did
nice good shooting one more dude he's on
the top he's heard pika cheeks get him
nice nice pika cheeks another zone gonna
do one more doom or two more dudes just
hang back I think we've still got a life
advantage or no overtime get the point
get the point
heavies coming heavies coming got him
one more he's outside Pikachu get the
heavy get the heavy get that me Stevie I
got you nice good chops good work boys
nice teamwork
yeah I just don't like that they're
coming all over you you know what I mean
banana well that guy's so [ __ ] hurt
there we go
[ __ ] you watch a flight - he's tearing
oh they're holding they're holding I
know yeah damn it big team hold on
having big time
Oh get in there get in there come on we
got a super [ __ ] sake should we try to
get this round I don't know because yeah
yeah use one of our shall we at least
one of them cuz I'm about to have mine
back soon oh my god
origin story why is this oh well there I
got a couple now there now we're almost
tied I'm back I'm back I'm out I'm out
guys did somebody who has their other
super I say use it I still got mine
I'm gonna use my right [ __ ] them wait
wait till they get close go where it's
heavy on the ship is heavy almost I feel
heavy comes up 29th I throw it up though
I just hold back Pikachu stay in that
rift just hold them off from heavy and
make sure they're not flanking and
that's all you can do
all right they're gonna come in for that
when they come in for that vulgar blow
that [ __ ] yeah I know they got one food
they got one too so don't stay close
don't stay close
get the heavy get the heavy if you can't
be her way watch out Steve think our
life is gonna kill who's gonna do
gotta get a kill get the heavy what [ __ ]
they have life advantage that's why we
had Wow solution is here well my Nova
didn't kill anyone I know
all right guys well we gotta we gotta
bang it out now they got one Nova so
don't don't stay too clumped let's cover
heavy stay back they're gonna come watch
out reach left
nice
Oh Oh Arthur Coco go get him Arthur oh
shoot nova bomb
he's the Nova bomb it's okay he used it
on me get him go he's in the RAF to your
left
hey honey yeah I got it three three
we're tied up what the [ __ ] oh my god
I'm an idiot
I'm back hold on think I'm sorry guys I
[ __ ] that know we're group we're good
we're good nice TV all right let's keep
that let's keep that
let's stay back let's stay together take
advantage I know I'm just trying to hold
them off
be careful
where you guys at we're here we're
watching heavy heavies coming
somebody grab that damn it I know oh man
it sucks we always do this we always get
close all right 30 seconds is heavy up
because we got it we got to go we got to
kill two lives dude we got to take 12
seconds sure got a grenade on me one
more kill we got to be aggressive we got
to be a [ __ ] to one - I know it's too
late we should have [ __ ] had an
[ __ ]
yeah that was a good game it's a good
game we should have had it
[ __ ] man how am I know about not killed
two guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]